right if you got here is an abundantly
gifted gentleman who not only
understands the problems of the actor
playwright and director but also as an
author knows the agony of facing an
empty page the impeccably literate mr.
Peter Ustinov
Thank You mr. Carson is more than
generous
he is accurate I know well the agony of
the blank page and I know too that when
words do appear at last and act to speak
them they are imprisoned on the
soundtrack for all time phrases which
have found their way into our vocabulary
just as they have entered our hearts I
am pleased to reveal the winner of the
Academy Award such as the purpose of our
gathering I was led to believe for the
best screenplay based on material from
another medium the nominees are breaker
Marant screenplay Jonathan Hardy David
Stevens and Bruce Beresford Coal Miner's
Daughter screenplay by Tom Rickman The
Elephant Man screenplay Christopher
Duvall Erik Bergeron and David Lynch
ordinary people screenplay by Alvin
Sargent
the stuntman screenplay by Lawrence beam
Marcus adaptation Richard rush and the
winner is Alvin Sargent for the ordinary
thank you I am very proud that you give
me this honor and you honor this film
which is about all of us trying to
understand all of us a movie that is
about terror and despair and pain and
all kinds of anxiety violence and yet
with no bullets no guns and no rapes and
no homicides and I'd like to dedicate
this to the actors and the my producer
Ron soiree and the exquisite taste of my
director and to there's a little house
on a corner in a street in Edina
Minnesota and their lives
Judith guests thank you
years ago I was interested to read one
movie critics review of a new comedy in
which he said it was a dismal effort
saved only by the frequent laughter
generated by an Southern's amusing
ad-libs critics have a way of endearing
themselves the nominees for the best
screenplay written directly for the
screen are Brubaker screenplay by WD
Richter story by WD Richter and Arthur
Ross Fame screenplay by chrystopher Dore
Melvin and Howard screenplay by Beau
Goldman monitor d'amérique screenplay by
jean briault Private Benjamin screenplay
by Nancy Meyers Charles Shire and Harvey
Miller
and the winner beau Goldman for Melvin
and Howard
I'm so happy and please forgive the
litany of gratitude but movies are made
on faith and the studio's money I'd like
to thank my friend Ned cannon for his
deep pockets
Jonathan Demi for his good eye art
linson and Don Phillips for steering me
to gabbs nevada and melvin howard for
sharing his life tonight I'm here for
Melvin and Howard but there are years in
between for me and for all writers when
there are no awards so tonight I'd like
to mention some men who've taught me a
lot and whom I love Phil Kaufman Alan
Parker Mike Nichols and Melosh Foreman
may I share this honor with my agent
Arnold steve-o and my wife mAb Ashforth
who urged me to write this movie and I'm
so glad I did
Thank You members of the Academy